fans in the United States and Canada I'm
David Amber and welcome in to Scotia Bank
Arena home of the Toronto M Poli and for the
next three days home to the brightest stars in
the National Hockey League I'm John Butcher of
ESPN NHL Allstar Weekend begins right now here
in Toronto we have four NHL Superstars future
Hall of Famers and icons are going to put on
their GM hats tonight and draft an All-Star team
these guys don't know who their teammates will be
yet David yeah let the drama begin officially
starting out the Tim Horton NHL Allstar player
draft tonight we're going to take hockey back to
its roots in 2011 the NHL began an experiment for
three editions of Allstar Weekend welcome to NHL
fantasy allar draft no longer would the game be
East versus West or North America versus the world
instead captains chose their team's playground
Style with the first pick we are proud to select
Steven stos my boy anre copar can't believe
I'm going to do this but Jonathan T now almost a
decade later the All-Star player draft is back and
captains will decide which Superstars will fill
out their rosters it's team Matthews led by Austin
Matthews and one of the biggest pop superstars in
the World Justin Bieber team McDavid led by Conor
McDavid and anyy nominated Canadian actor Will
aret team McKinnon led by Nathan McKinnon and a
singer songwriter with two number one top 40 hits
Kate McCrae and team Hughes led by Jack and Quinn
Hughes and five-time Grammy Award winner Michael
bé the Tim Horton NHL Allstar player draft starts
now again it's the Tim Horton NHO allar player
draft kicking off a three-day Allstar Weekend
here in Toronto Dave yeah it's going to be a lot
of fun it's actually the first time we've had a
draft here at Allstar Weekend since 2015 that's
right and this is how it works basically there
going to be teams of 11 four teams of 11 who will
play this Saturday for cash prizes uh it's going
to be really good we needed some help though when
we had to figure out the draft order and when you
need help who do you call on you call on the great
one how about the greatest one in Wayne Gretzky
determining the first overall pick at the hall
of fame and and there it and there it was with
that picture of Michael bé congratulations team
Hughes of course the co- captain win Hughes the
NHL's leading score for defenseman coming out
now as well as his co- Captain younger brother
Jack the three-time allstar still recovering from
that upper body injury and quin's teammate Alias
Pon playing in his fourth NHL allstar game is
going to be an assistant captain and there he
is the celebrity Captain a wink from Michael bé
a huge Canuck fan and a Canadian music legend
five time Grammy and 15 time Juno Award winner
team Hugh first overall pick right there team
hugheson will be the local favorites no team
Matthews led by the captain and seven time
Allstar Austin Matthews the NHL's leading goal
scorer Morgan Riley his first Allstar appearance
for the star defenseman of the Toronto Maple
Leafs and Justin Bieber the pop one of the
most successful musicians in the history he's
here Captain Matthews he's ready he's into it
assistant GM our third overall pick Captain by
Nathan McKinnon MVP favorite Stanley Cup champion
Nathan will be assisted by his teammate kale Mar
only man ever to win the Hobie Baker Norris Trophy
and con Smite it be Kale's third allstar game and
the celebrity Captain Canadian singer songwriter
dancer and actress you'll see her as our head
line performer on Saturday give it up for Kate
McCrae and our fourth team come a homecoming
Conor McDavid fourth overall pick on the E
Oilers he'll be helped out by his boy Leon
dryo and also another Canadian Arrested
Development Blades of gory and maybe the best
podcast going right now smartless will are
net so we'll have 36 players to choose from
tonight only one couldn't make it for prior
engagement he will be here tomorrow he will
play in the game but check out the Jumbotron
for the one guy who couldn't be here for
his short message hey guys sorry I'm not
there fortunately I was able to find someone
to fill in for me see you soon all right so
ref presenting Sid tonight is Ryan Owens
a seven-year-old Tim bit kid Tim Horton
so important to the hockey Community the Tim
Timbits program started in 1982 help more than
880,000 kids develop confidence learn teamwork
and social skills and most importantly have fun
he will play the part of Sydney Crosby Tonight
Tonight these 10 big kids will be passing out
jerseys to our first round players as they are
being picked all right well let's get right to
it the first four rounds the team will have
45 seconds to make their pick again it's team
Q's on the clock as we begin the Tim Horton
NHL Allstar player draft here we go sound is
chaotic that's oh we're miked up we are miked
up and we were on oh go um so either Crosby
yeah coverage there we go with uh need two
goalies before round seven yeah you guys look
C announc I didn't realize we have team you
guys look cute as hell right now we proudly
select love it from the Tampa a lightning up
first player chosen the NHL's leading Point get
right now a former MVP lightning off the board
to the team Hughes with the first overall pick
in this year's player DRFT that means team
Matthews with Morgan Riley Justin Bieber and
Austin Matthews they are officially on the
clock okay I think we know who we are we're
ready they're ready they woke up knowing from
uh Calgary Alberta by way of Stockholm Sweden
William NE [Music] William William and there
he is a leaf them team Matthews Riley and
Bieber he gets his first round Jersey there it
is number 88 on team Matthews is William neander
frame that one day all right Nate McKinnon third
overall pick two players gone did you go to bed no
you were going to take last night did I go to bed
no knowing who I had an idea uh we're going to let
Tate make our all right T make the announcement
um I I think we're gonna have to go as Sydney
Crosby I think you do I think you do come on up
coming up and the old school uniform there he
is Sydney Sydney Crosby of course was a Tim
bit kid I I don't know if that's Tim bit size
or Sydney size but so Nathan McKinnon with some
provincial love he gets his boy Sydney Crosby all
right Conor McDavid Leon D hello will great to
see you brother good to see you all right so you
got course the snake draft you're going to get
the next two get the next two that's a bit of
a strategy you got goalies out there we all need
two goalies right I think we're ready to roll what
was going to pick up we're ready to roll we know
exactly we know exactly who we want what kind of
player do you need we want somebody who's going
to make a difference we want somebody who's going
to tow the line we want Conor hellar whoa an early
goalie selection come on I me the the Oilers have
won 16 in a row they know def wins championships
and they're playing great defense lately we need
it we need you we need you USA born Conor H
first overall here in the great hockey City of
Toronto all right so that's the first four
picks David of our NHL player draft few
surprises there caught her hellu off the board
the first rounds in the bcks second third and
fourth rounds all coming up as we continue
the Tim Horton's NHL Allstar player draft
welcome back to Scotia Bank Arena the best and
brightest stars in the National Hockey League
congregating here in Toronto for the next three
days and one of those Stars a third time Allstar
Mitch Marner now Mitch we saw William neander
your teammate go to your boys you got to keep
the band together right you got to be on this
team ah we'll see are you going to lobby for
Connor not to take you with the next pick then
it's well they're drafted I don't know whatever
they want to do whatever they want their team
we'll see all right well we've got one round in
the books it looks like you're pretty open to
all the options available best of luck looking
forward as we start round two of the draft back
to you John yeah it is interesting McDavid or
McKinnon could try to keep some of that Synergy
away because they're playing you they're playing
to win on Saturday uh so maybe there's some even
some deals before the show we don't know all right
Connor you went goalie the first time around
controversial pick everyone's talking about it
on social media what about your next pick we know
what we're going to do I think they know you had
a commercial break right yeah I'm going let you
guys make the call but go ahead uh we think that
we need a little bit of goal scoring so we got
David P oh yeah carbo loading with pasta good
call these three on the ice at the same
time Le DAV having another MVP type season
in Boston this year despite his fellow Legends
retiring after last year so C her McDavid off
to a great start all right Tate McCrae announce
your next pick with kale and Nate uh pick we're
going to take it back home to Denver Colorado
and Alexander yeah you need a goalie why not
go with one that kale communicates with on a
nightly basis Alex gorv joins team mck they
take one of their two go we have eight goalies
here tonight to be chosen two gone so far six
to go and team Matthews is on the board
and Justin I want to know how much input
are you having with the picks tonight you
said what how much how much input are you
having with these picks I mean I'm trusting
these guys definitely trusting these guys
your buddy's still on the board here I think
I might know where this pick's going or maybe
they're going to go off the board uh Morgan uh
Austin look that way let him know who you're
taking let's do it get over here and there
it is aaf reunion on baby Mitchner joining
his neander Riley and Matthew goodness and there
it is that's a lot of Toronto round two Mitchner
and now it's four map Leafs on team Matthews and
that means team Hughes is on the board not for
one but for two picks it's a lot of Liberation
here brothers are crying they get two picks In A
Row D all right firstly we got to figure this
out I got to know this the first pick doesn't
matter the second are you playing D
or Center like I always want you to
play who stand we proudly select from My
Hometown Bank P Demco there it is goalie
taken by team Hughes and nice to get the kuu
players together the kucks with six players
and a head coach the most representation we've
seen at an NHL allstar game mat dco joins the
team yeah who's the fastest you guys are
on the board once again for a second pick
all right our uh third pick we're
going to go from the Winnipeg Jets
Kyle Connor wow sneaky goal scorer
Kyle Conor conck and jets getting
together man how you
doing yes sir good to meet you too First
Time allar Jake AER joining team Matthews
all right team McKinnon is your call of
course uh Nate you're were a Tim bit kid
right yep what's your favorite Tim Horton's
donut do you have one probably the Boston
cream let's go that's got to count right
number one overall donut all right you're
building a strong team who's the next
selection uh I see a lot of them uh in
our division so got to go with Carill
capriel oh Carill come on up what's up
buddy hi nice meet you so
carof of the Minnesota Wild
joinin so team McDavid once again has two picks
pretty good position to be in Connor obviously
went goalie first man you get pasta that's a
good value pick right there um what where you
going next you have two picks in a row yeah um
I think we need uh a defenseman there's there's
only a handful of them here right we're going
to go with Ros Miss do oh filthy Nobody Breaks
ankles like Rasmus D at the Blue Line this guy
is like a young Allen Iverson he is filthy he'll
join a strong offensive jugernaut right now you
might want to find a two-way player here any any
two-way players here okay what's that one more
pick it right away it out I don't know this we
have not discussed so this is happening on
the fly yeah what do you think will put on
your analysis here's my rule when it comes
to picking team hockey teams don't ask the
actor you know what I mean there um that's
I think John Candy made a few picks for the
K boys what do you think kind of caught us off
guard um what do you think goalie turn your mic
off first you really can't lose they're they're
all really good okay uh we will pick uh Robbie
Thomas there we go Robert Thomas there
we go met the lead singer of Matchbox
20 for a second was he here Robert
Thomas excellent offensive player
what so team McDavid continues to get Sol
he bu shaped up all right good call back
to McKinnon okay all right Tate how much
info do you have in all this pardon how
much input pick your favorite player you
know yeah I'm looking at the names uh I
kind of trusting the guys on this one um
Sebastian AO I think that's a pretty good
one he can do it all he can score he can take
a face off he'll block a shot if he has to so
Sebastian AO with the Carolina hurricane
the latest selection from Nathan McKinnon
Squad all right so it's Austin Matthews Justin
Bieber and Morgan Riley about to make a pick
you got your goal tender last round you're going
back to a goalie you're finding a forward what's
the plan uh I don't know I think uh we're to
go with a forward from the Arizona Coyotes
Clayton Keller oh yeah Arizona reunion you
know him so well you know his game I got my
guy Arizona golf buddies good to me too yeah you
guys go how far back do you guys go uh junior so
yeah 16 17 how cool is it that we're seeing
the growth of the sport you're in but really
Across America got to do you got to do a right
you love to see it and you know nontraditional
hockey markets and uh places like that it's
good to see more more kids playing hockey
picking up a stick and and just enjoying it so
well that's good and Morgan how much influence
are you having on these PS do you think Brock
will be yeah it's been fun um I think the picks
have been good so we got some work to do but I
think we're in a good spot all right so there's
team Matthews they get Clayton K and now we're
over to team Hughes he'll be okay been all over
the board not sure what to predict here team
Hughes we need another 10 minutes that's all
Michael what's the issue is there is there
issues guys AR yeah the issue is many good
hockey players we have literally the greatest
players on the planet and there isn't a bad
pick and so it's impossible to know which of
the greatest hockey players on our planet to
pick and I'm eating into our 30 seconds so
what's up boys where are we doing all right
you want to go first cap we're taking uh let's do
this all right from the Ottawa Senators Brady to
Chuck and look at this Brady K
Shu what a great pick the captain
Senator maybe a bit of a surprise there's still
some Vancouver K waiting to be drafted but team
H they found their man in Brady kachuck let's
recap now go through teams one through four all
right so team used the tail of the tape they
picked Nikita CRA on first overall they add
a star golender Demco then Kyle Connor and Brady
kachuck as they round out their first picks team
Austin Matthews they select William naner in
Mitch Marner as they keep the band together and
then Jake Ginger the goalie from the dollar
stars and Clayton K A Reunion of sorts from
Arizona and the Eminem boys McKinnon and Mar and
McCrae Sydney Crosby what a great selection for
them they get their teammate goalie early and
then Capri off and AO to round out them and
team McDavid they took the first goalie they get
pasta a defenseman and Rasmus Dalene and Robert
Thomas could do it all in the offensive end as
well so all 14 off to a good start David speed
rounds are coming up so keep it locked here it's
the Tim Horton NHL Allstar player draft welcome
back to the Tim Hortons Allstar player draft as
we continue on here a goalie has been taken by
each organization so far three three of them
American Born just like Jeremy swam so Jeremy
you're sitting here these four teams all need
one more goalie uh how nervous are you I see a
little sweat on the brow yeah uh I saw the two
names I was sitting between and I knew pretty
quick I was going to be cast on an island so I'll
work hard for you guys and hopefully uh we get
some good luck coming our way you anticipated
being here by yourself once you were with your
fellow guys I did I knew that pretty quick how
does a goalie prepare for an All-Star game like
this three on three you guys have the most
pressure on it uh what can you bring to one
of these organizations I think uh I'm really
glad that it's not counting towards my actual
stats but I'm going to do my job and hopefully
um help our team get a chance to win all right
we'll see if maybe your American Brothers the
Hughes will select you for their second goalie
David what are they going to do there has been
an American theme with Team Hughes their last
three picks have been Americans and some of the
national five cans matter they're debating it now
and then we can try to trade for MSY after there
all right make your P yeah yeah go go ahead man
all right from the New Jersey Devils Jer brat
and and there you go the man who is replacing
Jack Hughes at the allstar game Devil's
brothers and now Allstar Brothers as well up
R all right so team Hughes is made a selection
you're going to need a goalie I believe in your
next selection team Hughes and and we're back
to team Matthews okay we want to hear you guys
deliberate what your next pick's going to
be but I do have a question you see yes
for hair you guys play with obviously William
neander rock besser's out there who's got the
best hair in the league oh it'd be a close
tie between those two I think I don't know
maybe Willie though Mor what do you think
Willie always Willie all right so let's uh
here you guys still need a goalie you have
a few picks to make uh you Justin Morgan but
when you talk it through yeah I think we're
going to wait on the goalie right we already
talked it through I think we know who won from
the New York Islanders Matthew barzel oh he's
filthy like that that's aity Matthew barzel he's
going for the MVP award his third All-Star Game
fastest skater back in 2020 brother and it's a
British columia homecoming right and there it is
Matthew barcel well that was going on I I saw a
couple of Hughes Brothers pop over here and got
in Nathan McKinnon's ear I don't know if Elliot
Freedman is already tweeted this out but was a
trade offered you or something Nathan what was
going on just a mutual understanding he did me
a favor earlier in the draft so he wants me to
pay it back to him but Tate's going to make our
next pick here so okay so T did they influence
this pick or this is the pick you're going to
make yeah um they're saying we need to add some
grit so we're going to go with Tom Wilson perfect
nice we need somebody who's going to fight
Brady kachuck Tom Wilson we did size on the
squad so Tom Wilson goes to team
McKinnon all right team McDavid talk it through
will what do we need what are the deficiencies
what's going to bring this a championship on
Saturday we're playing to win we uh we've given
this a lot of thought we we've applied all of
our brain power to it okay and we thought you
seem disorganized last time I got to admit
but you see how hard it is for me to think F
every oce energy uh from Florida Sam Reinhardt
just having a monster monster season why would
you take a guy on a heater when you think of
hot NHL Commodities just Edmonton they've won
16 in a row and you think Sam Reinhardt Sam
grab your jersey right behind you now that's
a quality pick okay so everyone has to pick a
goalie now right because we're down the part of
the draft where you guys have to pick the four
remaining goalies and so you pick the first one
um what's up next for team McDavid yeah we got
to go another goalie um I think we're going to
grab Sam's teammate from Florida Sam bosski
or uh Sergey barosi [Music] Serge they go
thaty so Sergey bosi joining team
McDavid so team McDavid their current roster
as you see David dry pel early then they had
pasta Dalene robbert Thomas and Sam Reinhardt
couple of righties and then Sergey bosi in net
so now we're on to team McKinnon again you have
three goalies to choose from kale Mar you know
goalies which one you going to choose it's tough
they're all good yeah we've been told we got to
pick a goalie so um this guy's been all right
this year we're go with Jeremy Swan not bad
Jeremy come on over University of main product
Mike RoR Award winner welcome to the squad bro
y nice to meet you good stuff couple Hockey East
College hockey players kale Mar and Jeremy San
all right over to you David so well let's go
through team McKinnon Squad first again m the
car that's always a good start they get Crosby
with their first pick gorg of inet capriso AO
Wilson San all right team Matthews who's your
attendee all right so we need a second goenda
you have two options what do you have uh
we're going to go with from the New York
Rangers eigor shurin ano with a winner joins team
Matthews and rounds up their go how you doing
[Music]
what's so for team Matthews alongside Morgan Riley
they kept it in house with William naner and Mitch
Harner early on then they found a goalie in Jake
AER Clayton Peller and Matthew barzel with some
Junior ties to these guys and then eigor shurin
the vno winner a few years ago joins team Matthews
which firmly puts team Hughes on the clock and
I this is a pretty easy pick to make for you
guys yeah the goalie we get two now right uh but
you just just one we have commercial breaks too
so okay okay uh before the commercial break you
guys want to make this why didn't you make this
one dude uh which one you think I think Brock uh
from andur conect Brock besser oh oh wait you guys
needed a you needed a goalie though you have you
have take a goal hold on Brock Hold on he'll be
back after the commercial break you got to take
the rolles two goalies before the seventh round
so there's one goalie so we wanted we were going
to take the goalie but we thought we were just
cuz we had two in a row we felt like can we get
security down here please I feel like I just lost
a Grammy or an Academy Award or something tell
it you going to do the honors you're good go for
it go for it go for it all right cam talet let's
go camer there he is a home coming for cam T but
a second All-Star game for the Kings goalie had to
take your goalies before round seven we had we had
to we had your com me next all every and there's
team Hughes after seven rounds a distinct flavor
to this Quin Hughes team with Pon they had kerov
Demco Kyle Conor Brady kachuck yeser brat and
cam talbat rounding out the first seven rounds
of our NHL Allstar player draft okay well time
to take a break I think we know who team Hughes
will take next if they don't there'll be issues
in Vancouver we'll be back with that pick next
welcome back to a very busy Scotia Bank Arena
hockey fans from around the world keeping their
eye on this including Brock besser who's waiting
to have his name called and it was almost called
there Brock what's a guy have to do you're the
2018 All-Star MVP you're on Pace for 50 goals
what's going on here um yeah I don't know it's
just uh a new year and uh you know just a new
self mentally and uh it's been a great year
for our team so far everyone's been working hard
and uh our whole coaching staff has been great so
it's been fun has it been nerve-racking though
sitting through all these picks uh not too not
too bad because I got MSY and Lindy with me so you
got some teammates and some friends here your new
teammate too all right we're going to continue
this draft and it's team Hughes on the board and
your name we'll see if it comes up back to you
John yeah team Hughes is grinding right now I
don't know if there's dissension controversy you
make this Pi they brought besser over during the
commercial break I don't know what was said my
am I on the clock are we on the clock you're on
the clock need three more players let me just
say this on behalf of all my canu brothers and
sisters this is bull this is I I nothing that
happens tonight better cost me a Stanley Cup
you understand me I did my hair for three hours
for this moment we proudly select Brock besser
of he's wearing out a path on this ice back and
forth B Rocky for the second time for the second
time all right David Amber another player waiting
to be picked tonight yeah Nick Suzuki who is the
first Montreal Canadian player since Mark wrecky
to make back to back to back All-Star appearances
this is a different format do you like the format
yeah it's been cool so far I think the captains
are doing a good job and you know the guys
sitting here are anxiously waiting well the
Leafs and halves have a rivalry but do you want
to make any plea at all because it is going to
be Austin Matthews and Morgan Riley and Justin
Bieber making the next selection yeah hopefully
uh we can put the Rivalry aside maybe but you
know who knows it's a long rivalry for sure all
right that's the luck we got it three more rounds
John all right team Matthews uh Justin your squad
only has one defenseman that we talked about
maybe adding another another one or where do
you think the team should go right now awesome
what are you thinking is this our pick Austin
our pick we on the clock the clock um know who
you're going to pick he has the best mustache
in the NHL I quite Envy it uh from the Ashville
Predators Philip forsberg that is a lip sweater
it's the Envy of a prodigious Muzzy how you doing
bber and snip another finisher him Austin pitch
Matthew Clayton good stuff all right all right
team McKinnon what are we thinking here only
got a couple picks left so uh where you going
now with your latest pick well we we need an
agitator so no better guy than Travis Ki perfect
love it Travis Ki come on down you're on team
McKinnon all right you can take your time MC
T McDavid will Arnette Leon dry SLE you got
plenty of time to talk about it um again before
your selection Connor what about what does this
weekend mean to you um for those may be watching
in the United States they don't realize you grew
up around here what does this area mean to you
how did it affect you as a young kid growing up
uh yeah obviously it means a lot to me um you
know growing up in the area um this building
obviously watching the Leafs grow up um growing
up um yeah have a lot of family and friends in
town um especially for me 16 wins in a row your
team is on the heater you and Leon um what does
that feel like when you come to an All-Star
Weekend you take a break and you're still on
this this magical run does it make this more
relaxing and fun certainly a lot better than
where we were um you know we still got a long
way to go we dug ourselves a big hole and um
we're doing a good job of getting ourselves
out of it but certainly special to be on a
on a run like that um it feels good yeah five
more months it's a long season and a long way
to go but we hope to see you guys in June all
right so you look at the squad three on three
this Saturday Allstar format will Arnette uh
where are we going where do you think we should
go if you talk to the boys about I think we
I think we've got a consensus right yeah we
yeah that's unanimous you got it uh we're gonna
go with Boon Jenner oh boom Jenner they're not
booing they're saying Boon Captain the Columbus
Blue Jackets awesome for Boon to be at the allar
weekend
yeah what next what next so before your pick
conter you guys can talk about it well let's
go through the roster one more time all these
teams have one more pick to go we'll start with
Team McDavid there it is Leon and Connor goalie
early and latest pick Boon Jenner that's a nice
Squad right there lots a character and talent
team McKinnon with their celebrity C Captain
Tate McCrae just took Travis concy with their
last they got concy and Wilson they might be
short-handed in this game a couple times we'll
have to wait and see on that one David Amber and
team Matthews of course Austin and Morgan Riley
selecting two teammates William Mander and Mitch
Marner off the Hop and then AER and shurin are
their goalies hel barel and Philip forsberg as
Austin says with the best mustache in the game
round out their first seven picks and for team
Hughes they're contemplating things right now
Michael bé is very animated over there but he
likes the squad so far they've selected Nikita
kucherov the leading Point getter in the NHL
thater Demco Kyle Connor Brady kachu out a little
grit yes for brat Cam talet and Brock besser all
right one more selection for each team had
plenty of time to talk about it Connor we
know where we're going yeah I think so um will
do you want to make it yeah we're going to uh
pick a guy who's uh an awesome hockey player he
plays for a team that is a long standing rival
of the Leafs because he's a half My Team LEAF
is my hometown of Toronto wow but we're going
to pick Mr Nick Suzuki come on a lot of love in
the room Nick Suzuki how are you so Nick Suzuki
will join his team McDavid so we'll watch
Nick skate over there's his Squad saying
hi to his teammates for a day Saturday three on
three as we have four 11 player squads here and
Nick Suzuki is the latest to join team McDavid
all right team McCrae team mckinon team Mar mmm
you have one more pick to go yeah this could be
the Difference Maker think okay so I'm sad he
just got traded for my hometown team yeah you're a
big flame fan right M um so we're going to go with
Elias [Music] lenol yeah hearing that this weekend
wearing a flame Jersey so now one of those unique
situations where for the first time he wears
a kuu jersey here at All-Star Weekend Elias
lolm a lot of teams wanted him and Vancouver got
him and this team got him two team McKinna well
[Music] done and that puts Austin Matthews on
the clock there's been very little deliberation
you guys are kind of chill just going
about your business are you disagree on
every pick I think we just yeah we know who
we want and just make the pick easy as that
you have one defenseman you have your two
goalies and and uh what are you thinking
with your second last pick Morgan's going to
make this one Alex De Brat from the Detroit
Red Wings there he is Alex the bring
he's got a one time bomb second time
[Music]
allar and there it is you have a lot of undersized
forward on your team like Fast crafty guys [Music]
all right so Austin Matthews has one more pick to
make and here's the final pick up the eighth round
team use they've been talking a lot Michael D's
been doing most of the talking what's going on oh
I mean uh we're in heaven we love the team we have
beautiful are you kidding me um who wants to we
know the pick it's just a matter of who wants to
make the pick uh we got from Vancouver JT Miller
there is the rugged forward JT Miller what a
season he's had his first All-Star appearance
on Pace for 112 points he joins his teammates
on the Vancouver Canucks four Canucks on team
David it's uh uh five five withco never that so
my goodness it's the Vancouver Canucks versus
the Toronto M police when you look at these
two teams because clear r that show all those
so we have four players left we're going to take
a break and they're going to find out what team
they will be joining all at the same time when we
come back at the Tim Horton nhel Allstar player
draft back for the conclusion after this welcome
back to Scotia Bank Arena as we're ready to wrap
up the Tim Horton's NHL Allstar player draft and
again we' have eight rounds in the books we have
four players players remaining we'll get to those
players in just a matter of moments and of course
in case you're just tuning in team Hughes again
with Quinn Hughes and his brother Jack Hughes
as co- captains Alias Pon as the assistant and
Michael ble have selected Nikita kerov fer Demco
Kyle Connor Brady kachuck yes for brat Cal cam
talit Brock besser and JT Miller so count them
five Vancouver Canucks on that team for team
Matthews with Austin Matthews and Morgan Riley
and Justin as their celebrity Captain have
selected two Leafs backto back William naner
and Mitch Marner followed by Jake Ginger
Clayton Keller Matthew barzel eigor shurin
Philip forsberg and their last pick was Alex
De brinken okay team McKinnon with help from
kale marar and Tate McCrae Sydney Ki was their
first pick yor evet capriol AO Wilson Jeremy
Swan Travis ketne and the new Vancouver KCK lyol
they have one pick remaining and then team McDavid
Conor McDavid with help from Leon dry Sidle and
Will Arnett poock Dalene Thomas Reinhardt leoski
boom Jenner and Nick Suzuki so again each
team has 10 players they all have one more
to go we have four All Stars yet to be chosen
and they will be eventually chosen now and uh
we'll start with Nathan McKinnon uh different
format something you're not maybe used to how
do you like the new format it's good I mean I'm
not the best uh public speaker in the world but
it was fun I think the fans enjoyed it and uh
definitely better than years past for sure and
did Sid say hey I know what you're doing there
you better take me first round even though I'm
not going to be there in person just cuz you guys
go so far back I didn't even know he wasn't going
to be here until I saw on the video but uh yeah
obviously we're buddies it'll be uh fun to play
an allstar game together how nice is it have this
opportunity there's a lot of guys you're buddies
with but a lot of guys you probably haven't spent
a lot of time off fight with you're getting that
opportunity now yeah it's fun to hang out with
the best players in the league uh you know I
haven't met a bad hockey person and excited to
meet the guys on the the team and other guys
around the league all right thanks Nathan John
all right Nate's team needs one more dude you
guys need one more dude hello Jack hello Quinn
Jack uh you still came this weekend despite not
being able to play uh why just uh draft a team
my brother you know that's pretty fun so I think
we drafted a good team and hopefully they win all
right Quinn what do you think so far as you look
at the roster what did you think coming into this
uh how it would feel like and what H what end up
happening uh it was obviously pretty cool night
great atmosphere here and um you know got five
out of six Canucks something we were looking to
do but uh yeah happy with our squad team Hughes
is ready to go all right and I wanted to talk to
Tate McCrae because you have a big performance
coming on Saturday how excited are you for that
I'm so excited it's my first time at the allstar
game so I brought my Dad we're stok to be here and
I know you're Flames fans and it was a pretty you
know interesting trade obviously yesterday and
you said you're obviously sad to see Lind home
go what's it like when you go to the games and
you're in the saddle D it's so fun I was just
back in Calgary for Christmas and it's always fun
seeing my friends and cheering them on we'll be
cheering you on Saturday night so again we have
four great NHL players left bork strand vrono
hurdle and troch and the way we're going to find
out and how they will find out what team they will
be on we're getting from a living legend who is
in town his number is in the ra Rafters here in
Toronto he played an eight NHL All-Star games
he's in the Hall of Fame to help us deliver the
envelopes to find out where these fellas are going
Dave Keon let's hear it for the Hall of Famer
Toronto Mr Keon it's great to have you here and
uh this is kind of a cool moment as well how much
does this bring you back the allstar games you
played in uh there weren't as many people the
night before but uh it's nice to be here well
welcome back it's great to have you here what
we're going to have is the envelopes you have the
Timbits here with the envelopes they're going to
get the envelopes to you you're going to kind
of shake them up and the players will pull an
envelope and they'll know what team they're on
we should introduce the players as well Vinnie
troch uh Thomas hurdle would you guys like to
come forward uh Frank vetrano as well oh all
right first we'll get the uh the envelopes given
to Mr Keon by the these guys there you go these
have the the four teams inside the envelope so
Dave you mix those up a little bit just a little
bit of a shuffle and then pass them out fan them
out like a deck oh he's going to hand them out
so Random there's biny tro Thomas hurdle of the
Sharks Frank vrono olivander Brook strand of the
Seattle Kraken so these guys will open up the
envelopes and find out who they play for we'll
do it one at a time Vinnie will start with you
when you go first Vinnie open it up and find out
what team you'll be joining on Saturday at the
NHL allstar game team Matthews there's Justin
Bieber team Matthews and they played together
on the 2016 team North America Union of sight
what team will you be joining team McDavid
get some size in the middle Frankie shot come
on Frank patronos pride of Springfield Mass
chicken parm always on the menu ah team Hughes
Michael bé you get another Pacific time zone
player and speaking of the Pacific Division all
of York Strand hold on just a matter of moments
I think we know where this is going to go just
to confirm it Tate McCrae Nathan McKinnon
kale Mar welcome oler York Strand to your
team so don't forget what a great night this
was of course we have the skills competition
tomorrow that's 7:00 on sportset ESPN in America
and of course that also be another interesting new
twist here on Allstar Weekend and Michael you've
seemed very invested in all of this how do you
like your team now that it's all said and done
how do you like your team I love my team are you
kidding me what what do you love about him I love
that it looks early similar to my fantasy hockey
team that's in first place right now well that's
good news and Justin how are you feeling about
team Matthews feeling great feeling good good all
right he's feeling good Austin any last words to
you no we're looking forward to getting this thing
going so I know Toronto's going to bring the noise
for everybody it's going to be a good weekend
all right final words will will Nar you get the
final word about tonight you get the final words
on tonight's festivity well this is great to be
here in Toronto to be I'm not worthy to be stand
stand next to Mr Dave Keon it's so fantastic to
have him here uh just an absolute Legend to be
here with all these guys all these incredible
players who do this for living and come in here
and going to give a good show to all the fans you
guys make it possible we're just here to entertain
you guys well said well said all stars future Hall
of Famers Staley Cup champions all on this stage
and this is it this is the end of the Tim Horton's
NHL All-Star player DFT want to thank you all for
attending again this is day one of three days of
activities here in Toronto as we recognize the
best in the world and the biggest celebrities in
the world as well thank you so much for watching
and enjoy NH HL All-Star Weekend in Toronto